you know
i tried to come up with a nice clever
opening for this video on joss whedon
but um
i actually think the man himself said it
best
nobody ever fell from a pedestal into
anything but a ditch
[Music]
well
here we are again
i suppose it was actually a bit
optimistic of me to think i could make
it three whole weeks into the new year
before having to talk about
this kind of nonsense
so joss whedon
once the clever king of nerd culture
after about a year of keeping his head
down following a
lot of nasty allegations has popped up
again with an interview and accompanying
article in new york magazine
as a super quick refresher things
started going south for him when ray
fisher the actor cast by zack snyder to
play cyborg in justice league spoke out
about alleged unprofessional behavior
and bullying on the part of whedon on
the set of the extensive justice league
reshoots that whedon oversaw after
schneider initially left the project due
to a personal family tragedy
from there things snowballed as co-stars
like gal gadot ben affleck and others
came forth with their own stories or
stated their support of fisher in that
particular conflict then a whole bunch
of older stuff both known and new got
rolled into it as incidents on the sets
of shows like buffy got brought up most
prominently by charisma carpenter and in
a similar pattern others came forth
either to voice their own stories or to
show their support and their belief in
carpenter's statements those in the
industry defending whedon seemed to only
be stating that they personally didn't
have issues when working with him but
even some of those stated that they
could believe the kind of stuff that was
coming out about him whedon stepped down
from show running the nevers on hbo
ahead of its series premiere and
officially for creative differences
he hasn't really been seen or heard from
since
until now if you want more complete
details well we'll be going over some of
it but i also talked about this at the
time she'll be a link up there
so
this article has
not gone down well with folks we're
going to be looking at some of the
reasons why that is and i'm going to do
my level best to not let my own feelings
about the man or any of the things that
he is going to be saying over the course
of this to seep too much into things
because honestly a lot of what we're
going to be talking about speaks for
itself especially when placed in proper
context
i do however want to address a couple of
things just as quickly as i can the day
the issue of new york magazine came out
happened to be martin luther king jr day
and for those outside the us who might
not know it's a celebration of the
iconic civil rights leader who fought
for racial social and economic equality
now this led to a lot of folks on
twitter saying something to the effect
of real classy of joss whedon to slam a
black actor on martin luther king day
and yeah it was a bad look and we'll get
to what he said about fisher in a little
bit
but the man's not responsible for the
publication date the interview was
actually conducted months ago and he
doesn't control the publishing schedule
of new york magazine i'm not trying to
defend him but you know
let's save our anger for stuff he's
actually accountable for
just saying
the other thing i heard more than a
little was people saying that they
thought the article written by lila
shapiro was defensive on whedon's behalf
and seemed to be trying to paint him in
the best light at least somewhat
sympathetically and i i'm not sure i
agree with that although this isn't a
hill i'm actually prepared to die on
personally though the general tone i got
off the thing was that it was something
shapiro
really wished she didn't have to write
but to my eye it didn't come across as
trying to be overtly sympathetic towards
whedon
most of the instances doing things like
calling into question the motives of
whedon's critics again we'll get there
they were framed as being the
perspective of we nor of his defenders
and it didn't seem to me like the
journalist was actually taking that
perspective herself
again
not to me anyways though like i said i'm
not so confident in this perception that
i'm gonna wag a finger at people with a
harsher view of the article's tone
i'm more airing this out as a way of
explaining
why i'm not going to be diving into that
angle very much on all of this
what i will grant is it is strange how
much the article talks about whedon's
hardships growing up at the start of it
talking about his childhood and his
pre-career life almost as if the
original hope and intent was to have
more of a general profile but then the
issues of the last few years basically
overtook the entire middle and most of
the back end of the article which again
for me lent to that feeling that shapiro
had hoped the article would take a
different shape than it ultimately did
especially as the article tries to bring
the whole thing full circle towards the
end seemingly not realizing how far away
things drifted from the sections talking
about his initial pulp culture impact
again this felt more confused and at
odds with itself than actually
protective of whedon but that is my read
others have felt differently
i've stalled long enough
let's get to it
i'm going to be covering the issues that
are brought up in the article largely
chronologically as that's actually the
format the article itself is mostly
following now as noted there's some
rather extensive verbiage related to
whedon's childhood and his education and
then it gets into the days of buffy
angel firefly and even dollhouse there's
a very telling quote
from miracle laurie who worked on
dollhouse
she was largely positive in what she had
to say about whedon but then
she also added
this
i saw his kindness and his good
intentions but i also saw the snarkiness
the fickleness
where i would not want to be on the
other side
and that kind of illustrates what i said
before about those who had good working
relationships with whedon
still seemed readily acknowledging about
the darker sides of his personality even
if they themselves weren't ever the
target of them
and it's noted by shapiro in the article
itself that this dual defending of one's
direct experience while acknowledging
the harshness of the man was very
typical of the people she spoke with in
the lead-up to the interview now please
note that as we move forward some of the
people that get quoted in the article
gave their names
some did not i will note a name if it
appears in the article but many of these
stories come from unnamed sources and it
would be up to readers or viewers in
this case whether or not they have faith
in new york magazine's vetting and
source verification process
i think they have a solid enough
reputation on that but we'll move
forward from here let's start talking
about those who experienced whedon's
harsher side more directly this is where
we get stories like that that came from
costumer cynthia bergstrom who said that
during a disagreement on costuming
he grabbed my arm and dug in his fingers
and tell his fingernails and printed the
skin and i said
you're hurting me a writer on firefly
recalled a story where whedon was
unhappy with the script turned into him
and rather than give private notes he
called a meeting of the writing staff
and proceeded to tear apart the work as
if he was giving a lecture on how not to
write
the tv writer who told the story who
isn't the same one who was being
belittled recalled it thus it was
basically 90 minutes of vicious mockery
the guys were looking down at their
pages and this woman was fighting tears
the entire time
i've had my share of shitty showrunners
but the intent to hurt
that's the thing that stands out to me
now another member of the buffy
production team touched on whedon's
affairs with some of his actresses which
quick note is something whedon has never
denied happened though the identities of
the actresses has never been confirmed
by anybody involved
the staffer told a story about working
in her office when whedon and his lover
came into that office and began making
out despite the staffer's presence
they would bang into my chair how can
you concentrate it was gross
these actions proved he had no respect
for me or my work the article then goes
on to bring up what were the big buffy
error stories that came out when the
controversy was peaking
there was the apparent onset rule that
whedon was not ever to be left alone
with young actress michelle trachtenberg
this is a story that the article appears
to verify with one of the sources noting
that the rule existed but whedon himself
may not have actually been aware that it
did
now this whole thing appears to stem
from a closed door meeting between
whedon and trachtenberg during the
filming of buffy season six
which the source said left the young
actress quote unquote
shaken
exactly what did or didn't happen in
that meeting is unclear and isn't
something i'm going to be speculating on
but
the rule appears to have been put into
place in the wake of that and then of
course
there was charisma carpenter whose
issues with whedon on the sets of buffy
and especially it's been off angel are
well documented and were known prior to
all this but they came up again and
again i went into more of this in that
video that i linked earlier the short
version is that carpenters seem to be
increasingly stressed by whedon's work
manner leading to increased tensions
that peaked when carpenter became
pregnant and whedon was
let's just go with unsupportive for
right now
whedon denies the specific allegation
that he called a pregnant carpenter fat
though a story from buffy writer rebecca
x who wrote for the show as rebecca rand
kirschner
talks about encountering whedon while
she was pregnant sometime after the show
had ended and his reaction to seeing her
that way was oh you're fat
shapiro apparently spoke to rebecca x
multiple times in person and over email
and noted how she appeared deeply
conflicted about her experiences on
buffy with whedon in particular as
shapiro put it
shelves naded between criticizing whedon
questioning her reasons for criticizing
him and questioning her reasons for
questioning those reasons an example of
this comes in the form of her answering
her own question about whether whedon
was ideal like giving writers notes
no he's a blunt instrument but i'm a
very delicate receiver on the topic of
these stories and others about the
difficulties of working under him during
his show running days whedon
had this to say
i was young i yelled and sometimes you
had to yell this was a very young cast
and it was easy for everything to turn
into a cocktail party
despite that acknowledgement he
contested the specific accounts on the
subject of grabbing the costumer's arm i
don't believe that the staffer in whose
office he was making out that seems
false his handling of carpenter's
pregnancy i was not mannerly
okay
before we get into any further details
of what's in the article i need to take
a minute to just talk about how whedon
was responding to questions about these
incidents
honestly
the big question that i found myself
asking at this point as i went through
the article was
what is he hoping to accomplish with
this
i'm not entirely sure what i was
expecting but standard practice for
these sorts of things is either a
full-throated denial of everything or an
all-out maya culpa and plea for a chance
to be better whedon isn't really doing
either of these
or rather
he's kind of doing both or at least he's
trying to
while whedon is offering up denials of
some of the specifics he's freely
admitting to fault to the general tone
of the criticism being leveled at him
and even those denials are very soft
he's using words like believe or seems
and appears to be very careful not to
flatly call anyone a liar
and if you think i'm supposing too much
self-awareness on wean's parts
one of the very first quotes from him in
this article
is this
i'm terrified of every word that comes
out of my mouth he seems very aware of
how thoroughly examined anything he says
is going to be and is trying to walk a
very fine line as a result
but i'm not sure why he thought that
would do anything to help if he'd
doubled down for instance and insisted
that he never did a single thing wrong
he probably wouldn't have alienated any
more people than he already has and his
defenders would have clutched to those
denials and just rallied around him if
he'd offered anything approaching an
actual apology rather than these tacit
admissions of wrongdoings
maybe a few folks would be tempted to
give him a second chance but
by doing
neither one
it just leaves the situation as is or
rather it would
if it weren't for some of the later
quotes that um
we're going to be getting to this whole
aspect is infuriating because to my eye
at least whedon is displaying just
enough self-awareness that it makes me
annoyed that he isn't more self-aware
than this
he doesn't seem to lack the ability to
introspect but just doesn't appear to be
doing it very well
it'd almost be easier to swallow if he
had zero self-awareness or at least it'd
be easier to write the whole thing off
it's worth noting here that shapiro
notes several times following some of
the more direct questions whedon would
excuse himself to the bathroom something
he would later admit was a trick he used
when asked an uncomfortable question so
in some of these instances he excused
himself
thought about the responses before
giving them and this was what he decided
to say
but okay let's get back to it
as i noted earlier the identities of the
numerous women whedon had affairs with
has not been disclosed
and that fact alone
may have been part of what kept whedon
from being ostracized back in 2017
like he is right now because you see
back in 2017 was the year that kai cole
his ex-wife from who he separated in
2012 and officially divorced in 2016 she
put out an open letter with details
about whedon's infidelities amongst
other things again without naming names
talked about it at the time
had the women involved ever come forward
to tell their side
it's quite possible the specifics of the
power dynamic or how these affairs
started evolved or ended could have been
catastrophic for whedon not that cole's
letter had no impact it was the point at
which many people started to turn a more
scrutinizing eye to the once lauded joss
whedon but without the details on the
affairs people were left to decide for
themselves whether they were going to
choose to believe the best or the worst
of all possible scenarios but
of course there was no way the article
could just skip over the subject
so when shapiro broached the topic of
the affairs whedon expressed instant
regret though in
some frankly bizarre ways he noted that
it messes up the power dynamic which
okay i mean that's not untrue but it's a
very strange thing to focus on given
that he makes no mention of regretting
that he betrayed his wife's trust the
wording is also really strange because
yeah in workplace affairs the power
dynamic is kind of at the heart of it
especially in a situation where powerful
men having an affair with someone over
whom he holds a great deal of sway when
it comes to their career yeah power
dynamics matter but the way he says it
seems
more like he's concerned with how the
power dynamic is affected by having the
affair
not about how the power dynamic affects
the existence of the affair in the first
place which
generally speaking is the much bigger
issue
i know it seems like i'm reading a lot
into a quote that isn't even a complete
sentence but
i kind of have to
in order to prep you
for what's coming up
whedon went on to say that he
had to sleep with these women and that
he was powerless to resist
i'm gonna let that sink in for a moment
i kind of have to because it's such an
outdated notion in the vein of wasn't my
fault officer look at how she's dressed
it feels like parody
shapiro clearly thought so because she
writes in the article that she tried to
laugh it off
to which whedon replied
i'm not actually joking
this
is where some of the earlier sections
about whedon's youth
actually come into play because what
appears to be going on here is that
he was surrounded by the kinds of
beautiful young women he never had luck
with when he himself was a young man and
he
felt compelled to pursue them
because he felt he would always regret
it if he didn't
now i know i said
i was going to try and not bring too
many of my own feelings into this but
this
this is where i'm going to start
breaking that guideline because
the degree of tunnel vision
required
to see other human beings first and
foremost as opportunities that either
misses or grabs rather than as people in
their own right
look i want to say it's unbelievable but
i'd be lying if i said that because it's
not
it's familiar
unsettlingly familiar it's something
i've witnessed and if you go back far
enough into my own life it's something
that i've thought
one of the things i've been working on
the most about myself for going on two
decades now is to not treat people or
think of them as supporting characters
in my story
because they are their own person with
their own story not a bit player in mind
and
you might think that would incline me to
be more understanding of whedon but the
truth is if anything it makes me judge
him more harshly because that's a part
of my own life and history that i do not
look back on with
any degree of kindness
and i would be quick to point out that
during my worst stretches
i was a dumb 20-something in college and
then entry-level jobs
he's a professional in his 50s talking
about the things he did while being a
television showrunner in his 30s
because i recognize the thought process
i also recognize the deep level of
self-delusion it takes to think that way
and i can only imagine what it takes to
state those feelings years later with no
acknowledgment of just how twisted the
thinking was in the first place
so getting back to the article while
shapiro didn't interview any of the
women who had affairs with whedon prior
to his separation she did speak with
three of them who'd had intimate
relationships with him in the wake of
that separation and all three
had some very unflattering things to say
one woman a freelance writer who used
the pseudonym sarah for the article
talked about how he'd led her to believe
that he was single and then set her up
to go out drinking with a friend of his
who he said he wanted her to meet and
over the course of that conversation the
woman told sarah that she was dating
whedon
and had been for enough time to consider
him
a long-term boyfriend
then there's television writer aaron
shade who whedon paid to come to his
house and
quote watch him write on the condition
that she not inform her bosses the pair
then dated in secret for nearly a year
before she slept with him and soon after
that he broke up with her over email
last year shade detailed the entire
affair in a seven part youtube series
the playlist of which should be in a
video link right up there
and then there's arden lee author of the
new rules of attraction which was a book
about being a female pickup artist
and it does appear that she was the one
who initially picked up whedon and the
two then began a relationship from there
and they kept things going to some
degree for about three years at which
point whedon broke up with lee a few
hours before her birthday
now
that already isn't great
but i mean you know breakups happen and
there isn't really an ideal time to
break up
right
yeah about that in the epilogue of her
book
lee had recounted that one of her worst
memories ever was a boyfriend breaking
up with her on her birthday
whedon had read the book the two of them
had talked about the book they had
talked about the epilogue in specific
and i'll let the quote from lee sum this
up
if he was like what could i do to arden
that would be her worst nightmare that
would have been it
joss destroyed a beautiful thing just to
show he had the power to
that's literally everything you need to
know about him
so
remember what i said about the power
dynamics in the workplace earlier
well another thing that can contribute
to an unbalanced power dynamic is an age
gap not automatically but often and i
feel at this point they need to point
out that at the time of these three
relationships all these women were in
their early 20s and whedon was in his
late 40s actually crossing over into his
50s during the relationship with arden
i get older
they stay the same age
yes they do yes they do
[Music]
and now we arrive at the big deal the
project over which everything came apart
justice league
as stated earlier snyder's departure was
not an issue forced by the studio snyder
himself has said since then that in the
wake of his daughter's death he just had
no drive to continue the project it's a
passion he would later rediscover and
that ultimately yielded the snyder cut
of justice league
but at the time while the official
company line from warner brothers was
that whedon was simply coming in to
complete snyder's work the choice of
whedon already sounded alarm bells for a
lot of folks no matter what one feels
about the man's work there is absolutely
no denying the fact that he and snyder
have very different sensibilities both
in general and in regards to superheroes
in specific it's very clear that snyder
voluntarily opted out of the driver's
seat and warner brothers wanted the man
behind the mega success of the avengers
to come in and fix the project warner
brothers is still denying that this is
the case but the sense of 40 days of
reshoots including massive script and
dramatic tone changes would indicate
otherwise
fixing justice league is something
whedon was willing to attempt and now
openly regrets though how much of that
regret is over the project itself and
how much of it is due to the fallout we
are about to go further into is
anybody's guess
now
to a certain extent
some degree of tension onset was gonna
be almost inevitable
though whedon had been a script doctor
in his early days as a director he'd
never been brought in to bring somebody
else's vision to life only ever his own
so a cast crew and vision brought
together under another creator to say
nothing of one as different to whedon as
snyder is
was always going to be an awkward fit
for a man used to being in creative
control from the start of any given
project
but the reports of what happened on set
go beyond just new management growing
pains a rather significant part of the
tension appears to stem from the fact
that snyder had approached the writing
of the characters as a collaboration
with his actors it's been reported that
snyder frequently let the actors rewrite
their lines and guide the
characterization this gave the actors a
sense of ownership and a voice in the
characters they may not have had under
other directors in contrast whedon is
and always has been a you say the line
exactly as i wrote it kind of filmmaker
now one approach is not inherently
better than the other but the two
definitely do not work going from one to
the other in a single film production
and that drastic shift in creative
atmosphere seems to have been at the
heart of a lot of the things that we're
gonna get into as noted before the first
person to speak about whedon's onset
demeanor was ray fisher i don't think
it's unreasonable to say that fisher had
the most riding on justice league from
the get-go the rest of the cast all had
established careers to varying degrees
and gal gadot already had the first
wonder woman movie under her belt
but this was fisher's first film role
i mean unless you want to count the
cameo in movie trailer from batman v
superman and i'm not inclined to
personally
it wouldn't be surprising that a result
of that is that he was the most
personally invested of all the lead
stars
he quickly found his part not only being
rewritten but also cut down and
minimized
it was cited in the hollywood reporter
not long ago that when fischer tried to
voice his concerns for the direction
the character of cyborg was taking
whedon responded by saying
he didn't take notes from anybody
not even robert downey jr
things appeared to only have gotten
worse from there after the shoot had
wrapped fischer went on to go public
with his grievances against whedon and
the warner brothers executives that he
claimed coddled and enabled whedon's
behavior
we don't actually know as many details
about the clash between them as you
would think given that there were two
internal investigations at warner
brothers ultimately resulting in
remedial action being taken though what
that actually means remains unclear
though fisher was the first to speak out
he was not the only one gal gadot would
go on to say that whedon threatened to
make her career miserable for the
trouble she was giving him over rewrites
that she objected to
when shapiro brought these things up to
whedon
this is where the quotes that caused the
most consternation on twitter and some
other places
were said whedon made a general
statement that he doesn't threaten
people which is something that numerous
previous remarks from others over the
years would dispute and add to that an
unnamed actress from angel who did speak
with shapiro when this actress's agent
tried to get her a pay raise she said
that we called her at home and told her
that she would never work for him or
20th century fox ever again and when
this actress was told about godot's
recounting of events and the threatening
of her career the actress commented wow
he's still using that line
in regards to guru specifically weed
claimed she must have misunderstood him
and his meaning
or more accurately he said this
english is not her first language and i
tend to be annoyingly flowery in my
speech
okay this
this is where i'm really i'm
legitimately i'm done being nice first
of all he's talking about a woman who's
been acting in english speaking films
since 2009 secondly how condescendingly
dismissive to claim a simple whoopsie
lost in translation issue when things
like his tone and body language would
have made his intent all the more clear
to her and yes such a lovely dash of
casual racism it's not her first
language she doesn't understand bless
her heart
what the hell man what the actual hell
goodall was asked about this
interpretation of events by new york
magazine and she replied in an email by
saying
i understood
perfectly
now as bad as that was you'll notice
that whedon is denying things while
still keeping to his earlier tactic of
not actually accusing anybody of lying
not that it's actually helping his case
but i just wanted to note that
before we get to his responses to
questions about ray fisher it's whedon's
assertion that fisher's role was cut
down because the script and the
character has written didn't really work
and fisher's acting was bad
now whedon also cast out over fisher's
motives for speaking out with this
statement
we're talking about a malevolent force
we're talking about a bad actor in both
senses
what okay okay two things about this
firstly vicious quality as a performer
is not an issue here it may have been at
issue when script changes were being
made but the major issues that fisher
brought up were whedon's behavior
not the simple act of being cut back for
his part and even if fisher was terrible
in the role which his performance in the
snyder cut would dispute but let's not
get too hung up on that
even if that was the case it wouldn't
justify the kind of behavior fisher and
others described in terms of how whedon
behaved on set which again we've since
learned is pretty consistent with
behavior over the course of his entire
professional career so regardless of the
accuracy the dig on fischer's acting
ability is irrelevant and unwarranted
secondly let's unpack the second meaning
of bad actor in this context it would
mean a person acting in bad faith or
being deliberately deceptive and through
all of his weak-ass and even
condescending denials that we've gotten
from whedon up to this point this is the
first time he has brought the motive of
the other person into question
and there are two key differences that
we have between ray fisher and the other
people that we've been giving responses
about
firstly ray fisher is a man which i
normally wouldn't consider a factor
except given whedon's deeply tarnished
image as a feminist he may have been
more cautious about talking about women
lest that get thrown back in his face
but the second difference is that fisher
is black
all of the women that are named in the
article since we can't confirm for any
of the unnamed sources
they are varying degrees of
light-skinned the only possible gray
area being gadot who's israeli but
regardless of whether or not anyone
wants to argue
whether that particular heritage does or
doesn't qualify her as a person of color
nobody would look at her and think of
her as being black
now
am i saying that whedon calling into
question the motives of the only black
man mixed up in all this when his
comments on everyone else were varying
degrees of soft or waffly
does that make him racist
i'm not saying that but i'm also not
gonna say he definitely isn't either
what this is at best is a deeply bad
look where the speaker didn't stop to
think about how what he was saying was
going to come across that is the
most generous that i can be when looking
at all his statements and realizing he
effectively went
i don't recall the things those young
white women are saying that i did it
doesn't seem correct to me that israeli
woman must have been mistaken about my
meaning because of the way that i speak
and
english not being your first language
but that black man
no he's
lying and what's worse
the bad actor comment
focusing on that second duplicitous
meaning opens up a can of worms that
whedon doesn't know how to handle
because the instant you take the
position that somebody is a bad actor
the immediate question is why
because people make bad faith arguments
for reasons for motive and this is where
we have to bring in some of the ugliness
that has been going on in fandoms over
all of this because when fisher first
spoke out remembering he was initially
the only one talking about the set of
justice league defenders of whedon's
honor began floating some very
conspiratorial narratives which the
article itself points out these included
completely unfounded theories that
fisher was secretly doing this at the
bidding of zack snyder or that snyder
had somehow tricked fisher into thinking
whedon's behavior was racist in order to
rile that in order to rile him up and
get him to speak out that would in some
way lend more credence to the entire
release of snyder cup movement which
okay this is such bull but real quick
one this is the kind of absolute bat
conspiratorial nonsense that has been
floating all over fandoms lately it's
the same general mindset that claimed
disney was bribing critics to bad mouth
batman v superman it's inane nonsense
but more insidiously is point two these
people wouldn't even grant fisher the
agency of their own convictions this
upset black man isn't smart or proactive
enough to do this on his own he must be
doing as somebody's bidding or because
he's just a brainless patsy oh and as a
bonus when this kind of bizarre
conspiracy narrative was making the
rounds these same folks also argued that
charisma carpenter was swayed by the
negative press into seeing a complicated
working relationship as simply being
abusive so let's add attempted
gaslighting onto the conspiratorial crap
pile
look i'm sorry for bringing up this kind
of disgusting nonsense but seriously
fandoms this has to stop
now the thing is
these theories were making the rounds
among whedon's defenders they weren't
being espoused by whedon himself or at
least they weren't up to now because
while we never affirms a belief in any
of these narratives specifically nor
does he state these wild theories on
motive he did
say
this
i don't know who started it
i just know in whose name it was done
and that
that implies a lot and what it implies
is dark and leans into the most toxic
inclinations of modern fandom and the
thing is whedon really should know that
because the simple fact is that many of
snyder's fans assaulted whedon
relentlessly online and in forums and it
only got worse
as everything about him came out so
whedon is fully aware we know he knows
this happened because of this
the beginning of the internet raised me
up and the modern internet pulled me
down
the perfect symmetry is not lost on me
that he could be aware enough to
recognize all that yet not aware enough
to realize that even implying devious
motives to fisher's actions is going to
lead to worse things happening in terms
of his fans going after fisher the fact
that he doesn't realize that is
infuriating although then again that's
me being generous it is distinctly
possible he is fully aware and just
doesn't care
there are a few more direct quotes from
whedon that i want to bring up because
i think they matter but they didn't fit
properly into the sections of this video
as i was laying it out
whedon really seems to want to trace his
woes back to 2017 and the publishing of
k cole's open letter about their
marriage i was made a target by my
ex-wife and people exploited that
cynically she put out a letter saying
some bad things i'd done and saying some
untrue things about me but i had done
the bad things and so people knew i was
gettable again there's a bit of a
conspiratorial bent to this
and
it's also a bit of an odd claim in terms
of the timeline of events because it
would be three years between the
publication of the letter and fisher
speaking out so the idea that cole's
letter waived a signal flag that
everybody responded to doesn't
line up
in a similar vein
there's this quote
once someone lights a fuse and people
see there's a flame they run to it and
throw stuff into it
now
i won't deny
there's a certain amount of truth in
that broadly speaking
it's certainly been true in the wake of
things like me too
where the first person to speak out
about misconduct has a tendency to open
the floodgates
for those who have been hesitant to
speak out before
the thing about that though is even if
they only came to
throw things on the fire after the fuse
was lit
they have
things to throw
it's not nothing not being public with
these kinds of issues in the past does
not negate the truth of the matter
which is something that has become
increasingly evident in the film and
television business specifically where
moving against the wrong person gets
your career ended such as whedon himself
allegedly threatened to do to multiple
people
i will never stop being annoyed at the
oh
look at all these people saying stuff
about me now that i'm vulnerable tactic
because it doesn't address the fact that
these people have stories to share and
the reason they do is because of you and
your actions
but as noted whedon wasn't totally
devoid of self-critique in his own way
could i have done marriage better don't
get me started
could i have been a better showrunner
absolutely
should i have been nicer
i didn't cut that quote short he did
stop there initially and after thinking
about it and in light of the fact that
he has at least tacitly admitted to
being heated or harsh or misunderstood
in the moment he felt that this
was the answer
he wanted to give i think i'm one of the
nicer show runners that's ever been
nice execution you're doing terrific
i can't imagine this article is going to
do anything to rehabilitate whedon's
image in the public or in the industry
i'd honestly be surprised if he's
granted the kind of budget and support
he'd been getting from entities like
marvel or even hbo anytime soon
if ever again
it's not necessarily that it's because
the accusations against him are the
worst in the industry they're
very much not bad as they are
but rather
it's because unlike folks like say
gina carano james gunn amber heard whose
actions were all offset the controversy
about whedon has to do with his behavior
on the job itself folks in hollywood not
wanting to employ him isn't just a pr
thing it's about not wanting to work
with someone whose actual onset conduct
is at the heart of the problem
that's not to say we'll never hear from
him again
independent studios even self-financing
it's still a thing
but it's going to take years of him
working small scale
with no issues before he'd even have a
prayer of getting a big canvas to work
on again
if that's even possible and it may not
be
as for his legacy well now that we now
have stories about his conduct going all
the way back to buffy his legacy is
definitely tarnished
but it's going to be up to each
individual viewer to decide on
how that impacts their love of his work
speaking personally i don't
actually plan to get rid of my complete
buffy box set
but i also don't plan to re-watch it
anytime soon
if ever
i mean i'm kind of sentimental that way
heck i
i actually still have my harry potter
related stuff my slytherin gear it's all
packed away i don't have to look at it
but
i haven't had it in me to actually throw
it out
because i remember what it meant to me
in the past and that
that still means something
now
whedon's earlier work
had been getting a critical reassessment
even before all this blew up so i'm not
about to call even his best work
flawless
things like buffy that were viewed as
progressive in their day have looked
less so
as times have moved on
but there can still be value there
though i would want to caution people
about letting their love of his work
turn them into defenders of him as a
person
conversely it also throws me off when
people who demonize whedon as a person
feel it's also necessary to argue that
his work was never any good
both of these positions that liking art
means defending the artist or that a bad
person's art must also be bad they seem
to stem from a core idea that only good
people make good art and that
has literally never
been true what i want everybody on all
sides of this thing to remember is this
somebody can be your creative hero
without
also having to be your personal hero
and no that's not the same thing as
separate the artist from the art i've
said my piece about why that doesn't
work rather what i'm saying is you are
allowed to evaluate the work and the
person individually their value does not
have to correlate you can dislike one
and like the other
ian from passion of the nerd who i do
consider a friend and is continuing to
do excellent work with episode by
episode deep dives of whedon's work
addressed this very well in a recent
comment response i'd advise you to pause
and give it a full read
while i've made the choice to disengage
from works that feel the most uniquely
whedon like buffy angel and firefly
i was already fine not revisiting
dollhouse i'm pretty much mirroring
ian's approach when it comes to whedon's
contributions to the marvel cinematic
universe i'm not about to pack away my
copy of the avengers
partly because it's easier for me to see
the contributions of the actors and the
crew who were already in place and would
have been there making the movie
regardless of whether whedon did it or
somebody else
but i mean that's where i'm at
you may be somewhere else but
no matter what
boy would he have been better off just
not saying
anything
so
that is everything i have to say
about
the article on joss whedon and his
comments contained therein
it's a lot to deal with
and it's never fun and it's never
pleasant
but i have been making the argument that
it is responsible
entertainment consumption to grapple
with these things
and it is irresponsible to ignore them
and i try to live up to my own standards
to the best of my ability
what are your thoughts on this
i do ask i know this is heat and i know
i certainly am not feeling kindly
towards whedon try to avoid name-calling
and
bass or gross personal attacks
i will delete those comments
but if you can keep that restrained
then i want to hear what your thoughts
are on this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
patreon is what keeps this entire
operation up and running and allows me
to do
what you just saw me do
and the amount of support is helpful
there's also youtube memberships
link down in the description for the
patreon as well as for all the other
stuff i do
twitch instagram tick tock etc etc
but um
don't worry too much about it
at the end of the day
my friends
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
thanks for sticking around into the
credits none of this would have been
possible without my patreon supporters
in particular i want to thank robin
powell tracy scrabbit vincent paul
fardalucci robin moore jayla gourle and
bookworm
thanks for keeping this going and to
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye
[Music]